I've always wanted to make a movie about
what it's like to be out there and alone
and sort of build upon some of the
anxiety that I probably feel about what
that would be like with this drama you
have the cinematic opportunity to make a
big screen that really transports people
I felt like we could do it in a way that
was completely immersive what they
endured at sea none of us can quite
imagine it in this era and the
interesting thing is is that even though
this was a way of life hunting whales
this was an industry this was the energy
industry of its time you know I never
really put two and two together in that
regard but this is the way they were
lighting the streets of big cities
around the world once a mythic idea this
had happened in our world I believe you
have seen things no one else to see when
warner brothers began to sort of see
what our approach was they felt it was
gonna be appropriate for imax and i was
very excited I'm a storyteller and this
is really the way this movie has been
designed to be experienced it's not just
to see it you know there's that there's
a it's it's the sound design the music
and of course the visuals you know I'm
meant to be a big a big screen
experience
so it's true yes too much is true
you